سفيان امرابط مغربي لعب لهولندا وبديل
محتمل لبوسكتس في برشلونه منذ تالقه في
كاس العالم 2022 مع منتخب المغرب اصبح
سفيان امرابط اسما مالوفا في كل العالم
وتبحث عنه محركات البحث دائما انتظارا
الانتقاله الى احد كبار اوروبا ورغم ان
ذلك جعل تفاصيل مسيرته معروفه بالنسبه
للكثيرين الا ان هناك اشياء مثيره حدثت
منذ طفولته وحتى الان لا يعرفها الكثيرون
عنه مثلا انه في طفولته كان امراض يريد ان
يصبح طيارا في حال لم يصبح لاعب كره قدم
ولكنه احب كره القدم بسبب اخيه الاكبر نور
الدين والذي يعد ملهمه طوال مسيرته
الاحترافيه ارتباط سفيان بالعائله كبير
لدرجه انه لا يتخيل حياته بدون طعام
والدته الذي يصفه بالافضل في العالم كما
ان حياته مع كره القدم منذ طفولته وحتى
الان كلها ارتبط بشقيقه حتى لعب سويا
بقميص منتخب المغرب وتالق معا ام رابط لعب
لمنتخب هولندا تحت 17 عاما ولكن مسؤولي
الاتحاد المغربي لكره القدم تواصلوا معه
ليلعب مع منتخب المغرب وبالفعل انضم الى
بلده الام بناء على رغبته ورغبه شقيقه نور
الدين والعائله باكملها ويرتدي امرابط
الرقم 34 منذ سنوات وسر ارتدائه لهذا
الرقم مع الانديه التي لعب لها خلال
مسيرته يرجع الى زميله عبد الحق نوري الذي
دخل في غيبوبه قبل نحو ست سنوات والذي كان
يرتدي الرقم نفسه مع اياكس قبل ان يبتعد
عن كره القدم ام رابط اكد انه سيحتفظ بهذا
الرقم حتى نهايه مسيرته وفاء لصديقه في
عام 2017 ظهرت صور لسفيان وهو يرتدي زي
رجل الشرطه وفي الحقيقه كان ذلك جزءا من
حمله اطلقها نادي اوتريخت تهدف لجعل لاعبي
الفريق يمارسون مهنا معينه للاحساس بمتاعب
الوظائف خارج كره القدم واختار امرابط ان
يكون رجل امن لمده يوم واحد سفيان حصل على
اشاده زلاتان ابراهيموفيتش الذي قل ما
يشيد باحد اللاعبين حيث وصفه بعد مشاهدته
في كاس العالم 2022 انه لاعب استثنائي
ويمتلك قوه بدنيه هائله وامكانيات كبيره
تعرض شقيقه نور الدين لفقدان جزئي في
الذاكره نتيجه اصابه بارتجاج في المخ بان
مشاركته في كاس العالم 2018 وتحدث بعدها
عن ذلك الامر مؤكدا انه نسي بعض الاشياء
التي تتعلق بالمباراه التي اصيب فيها
وكذلك بعض الاشياء التي تخص طفولته ولكنه
بالطبع يتذكر كل ما جمعه في طفولته بشقيقه
الذي رهن عليه قبل الجميع وكذلك انه بات
اليوم واحدا من افضل لاعب الارتكاز في
العالم على الاطلاق
[موسيقى]